good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Wednesday it's hump day our
favorite day here at the morning toast
we are finally back live in-studio hope
everyone had a great long weekend
enjoying the good weather today it's
bright and sunny finally our first we've
been in the studio for two months the
Sun finally came out you could see how
beautiful our view is take a look look
at the boats behind me the smokestacks
so beautiful um and it's just a great
that it's Wednesday but it feels like
the beginning of the week yeah oh I mean
the fact that this was a short week is
truly like what did we do to be so
blessed I don't know oh but what did you
guys do to be so blessed because we have
new merch shopping today who have a st.
Patty's Day teaser I am wearing mine
right now I'm gonna move my mic to show
you it says kiss me I'm toasty I'm
wearing the size extra large honestly I
could have gone for a size large even
though my ring and it says as a dress so
this one's a little big but they're so
cute for st. Patty's Day and then just
for life yeah if you're looking to get
down the st. Patrick's Day have a look
at shop morning toast comm dropping
today at 12 p.m. Eastern Time we have
t-shirts that say kiss me I'm toasty
they're green just like you're Irish
Fairweather friends and I think that
everyone needs one I agree if I see you
on the streets of New York being a drunk
mess not wearing a toasty kiss me I'm
Irish t-shirt then we are no longer
friends
totally also they are available for
pre-order so you can get as many
whatever size that you want they'll ship
in two weeks and everyone will get what
they get and they don't get upset we
also have a few items left from our
previous subgroup March drops which were
the toasty tipsy toasters flasks which
are so cute they're pink flasks you need
them for a st. Patrick's Day also silly
I don't get it
it's a bundle deal for having an open
container and then we have another
bundle deal which is our hot and toasty
merch which is a pair of undies that
come with three condoms toasty condoms
so check it out shop morning chest calm
the other subgroup merch stuff is up
right now but these kiss me I'm toasty
shirts will be up at 12:00 p.m. Eastern
Time so shortly after our show wraps
today so enjoy the show get your
merchants and go have lunch with rocks
which rocks we actually of a great show
today why actually we always have a
great show no but sometimes the stories
I'm like not so excited about it we both
watched Vanderpump rules and there's a
lot to discuss there's a lot to discuss
we're doing deer toasters Theo's here he
has so much energy we're doing deer
toasters I got my fantasy cards if
you're watching live you see I look like
dr. Phil Andy Cohen I'm very excited
about my turd
it's very very exciting it's all very
exciting we have new film on our windows
we have our new couches the show is
really just shaping up to be you know a
big competitor in the daytime space I
totally agree these couches are so
comfortable yeah I just feel like it's
really gonna enhance our performance
yeah we actually have two more couch
pieces coming but they're not here yet
but we you know what we can't wait for
life we have to start without it just
have a new rug coming I'm really excited
about I just think like it's an exciting
time to be at Osteria speaking of which
get your merch it does come in time for
Saint Patrick's Day so you don't have to
plan an outfit this is the whole the
whole shebang yeah you actually look
like you are going right after this to
Molly's pub no I really look like I'm
going to like a day party and I'm gonna
get down I think now that we have this
merch like I'm sorry but I think we have
2 dharti I know you don't like to dirty
but I think we have to I love to dirty I
prefer these days no I always I will
still take a dirty I prefer it over a
nighttime event every single time yeah
because I can drink a lot and then I
have time to have my fave over before I
go to sleep I wake up feeling like a
million bucks
should we do our date this weekend it
seemed Patrick say he's like next month
no but let me you said you loved it so
much let's do this weekend okay but I
mean there's like dirtying in the city
is very sad oh my god because you like
setting stumble out of a bar everyone's
like go to work no and it's like you
just walk into a pile of trash yeah it's
there's no sunshine no vacations rding
is one of my favorite like activities
it's one of the highlights of life do we
have to take a vacation I guess that's
what it means I do think that we should
take a vacation regardless I think we
just all should be taking more vacations
we were actually supposed to be on
vacation this week but we decided to
cancel our honeymoons and go to work for
the toast so I think we should do just
that
I think so too I think you know we can
get right into it we're gonna bring up
Vanderpump rules very topical episode I
feel like we're gonna have a very heavy
discussion I think we might as well
people on Twitter are having very heavy
discussions Oh I haven't looked at
Twitter I kept online to see what people
were saying because like my love of
Bravo and my love of talking about
canceled culture are now finally
converging into one and I wanted to see
what people were saying and there was a
mixed bag but a lot of people are just
assuming Brittney and Jax
feel the way that their pastor feels and
I feel like to blame to blame someone
for what someone they know says is one
of the most dangerous things you could
do like it's just it's not fair but how
could they I I haven't seen anything but
how could people really think that no
they really do
that's so crazy but we'll talk about it
so without further ado it is time is it
yeah well I just I hung up our clock the
other day so let me check the clock even
though I can't see it from here but I
think the clock is what it's saying is
that it's time the clock doesn't have
numbers on it I have no clue well what a
dumb [ __ ] clock okay no it's so it's
just like a circle with no with two
hands with two hands right so I think
it's about 9:45 and I can I can
literally barely tell the time when
there are numbers so now that there's
not I believe that this clock is saying
it's 10:00
Oh 10:30 yeah that actually makes sense
it's very confusing I think a heart like
telling time do these teach kids how to
tell time like on an analog clock I hope
so I'm sure that they do if they're
still teaching them how to like write
and you scrip that's true I don't think
they are teaching them how to write
script
that's really sad I can't wait to like
write their wedding thank you I can't
wait to have a kid and then like to see
what's changed in elementary school
curriculum yeah but then I think as a
parent like you get really heated about
what your kids are being taught do you
think that kids are like being allowed
to use calculators more than we were
because because they can't make the
argument that we're never gonna have a
calculator calculator in my pocket
literally in my hand at all times so
wonderfully letting kids use the ti-83 a
little bit more oh I don't know that's a
good question but we'll never know
because our kids are gonna be
homeschooled all right yeah because
they're never leaving the house yeah oh
right oh my god my kids never leaving
the house and whichever ëismí I have to
get my dental degree I had only to
medical school but we have doctor for 10
min for all of their internal need I
want to get like a twelve-year-old on
the show sit them down and be like what
do you do all day yeah I think it would
be really sad what do they teach yeah I
know I think it would be taking up tic
TOCs
well that's not sad to me but I think
they are on their phones with their big
headphones on wait renegade renegade
renegade when it's but I'm done doing
the renegade everyone's I was Oh Jackie
got slammed on tick-tock people were
saying this Lee and the tick toes
yeah the toasters were saying that
Jackie dances like James Charles and now
she's officially stopped dancing yeah it
was just hurtful but then I was like I
kind of like James Charles and I
understood my people were saying it
because of our hands yeah and they
really do have like long lanky hands
and when I was doing that and the spooky
wood you taught me as spooky like it if
you even watch if you watch the video
where you teach me the renegade like
that's what made me laugh and you're
like spooky but apparently it's suppose
to be more like crazy
well it's its interpretive it said
whatever you want I just think for
someone to compare you to James Charles
like to me there's nobody in the world
who's a better dancer than you like I
said every wedding like the music stops
and everyone just watches you dance like
you are truly in another world like
should have been a professional dancer
and James Charles is the epitome of
someone with no rhythm and a terrible
dancer who couldn't dance if his life
depended on it and that's why people
like like watching his tea talks cuz
it's funny so for someone to even
compare the two when you are truly
nothing of the sort I thought that was
shocking you know what it made me
realize like maybe I'm a good dancer and
like wedding scenarios but maybe I'm not
a good tick-tock dancer not a good
choreographed dancer yeah I used to be
growing up but I also think like I'm
tick-tock like the way that like Charlie
D'Amelio like does her body roll and it
starts at her head and you literally see
the roll go down to her toes I'll never
be that I'm nothing of the sort
yeah I have to agree I'm neither nothing
of the sort and either so I think it's
important to know who you are I only
started on tick-tock to just have fun
and that's what I'm doing so I'm about
to talk I'm not gonna make you feel bad
about it I want to take talk to be
famous so follow me at girls no job ok
are you ready for our first story yeah
because the rumors aren't you say the
thing I think so ok no I didn't know my
gosh ok abort abort
Wow well you were really about to just
rush right through that you have
somewhere to go sorry it's like without
the ads I have no clue who I am I know
we've no ads this week because we were
suppose to be on our honeymoons but we
decided last minute to come back and
like no brands we're ready for us it is
time for the best 5 stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast you
know I've actually not had a piece of
toast in quite a while but every time I
do I'm like Tim this [ __ ] is good I'm
like this is fabulous I should do this
more he should make a morning show about
it yeah I love butter too oh yeah we
were talking about this yesterday how a
bread basket is like so underrated did
we talk about it on the show oh did we I
think so but yes honey we did ok ok well
rumors are flying that John Cena and
Shea are engaged
Bouchet his girlfriend remember we did a
whole story on her oh my god this is a
girl he was photographed with yeah
they're still together they're still
together and now rumors are flying that
she's engaged because she was spotted
with a ring on her face
I mean this is always what happens
[ __ ] Nikki Bella like getting the men
ready for marriage he chickens out and
then the next girl gets to pick up the
guy who's ready for marriage
yeah but it's also very curious timing
obviously because Nikki Bella just got
engaged and she's pregnant yeah though I
don't think that you have much to do
with each other I don't think John Cena
man who like never wanted to get married
was said and be popping the question
just because Nikki's getting married and
by the way there's a difference between
popping the question and getting married
a lot of guys like get engaged but never
get married so until I see a veil and
you know stomping of the glass and a
ceremonial tally around John Cena's neck
I will not be convinced yeah I I hope
it's true though because I want like
happiness for him but it's just the
whole thing is so crazy to me I bet you
can't just like brand yourself as the
guy who's never gonna get married and
then like you find another girl and you
get married like that's just not fair
how it always happens though always like
George Clooney literally always justice
for Stacy Keibler and the Keebler elves
yeah and the Elizabeth Canales that he
was with I don't remember her all I
remember was everyone was like Stacy
Keibler's gonna be the one which it
makes me think that I feel as though Leo
is gonna get married soon people are
like really because the time is up like
time's up no you know I mean like he has
been you know on the model train for
many many years and he's never stayed
with someone as long as he stayed with
kami Marone and I think that and I think
a lot of people are thinking that his
timing is very curious and he took her
to an award show which he's never done
like I think she's to do that stuff with
Giselle well of course but I think that
she might be the one I think she might
be the one noise of Hannah Montana she
could be the one she could be the one
I just think it all gets old you know
I've been reading a lot of the books
that I read over the weekend had to do
with just like living in the spotlight
and living The Bachelor life definitely
gets old
yeah and one day you just wake up and
you're done and you wanna be a person
that's next to you it's that that's
where you plant your right and like men
don't necessarily have biological clocks
but I think at some point in their lives
after [ __ ] around for so long they
wake up and they're like what do i what
am i leaving behind like they look in
the mirror they see that they're old and
they're like I don't have a kid no and
you've been to every party like you've
done every drug use every party you know
what's gonna have like you go somewhere
and you know what's gonna happen next
you've lived it a million times and
you're ready for a change sometimes I
change is just stability yeah I know I I
totally agree so this might be the one
for Leo and one of the books that I read
this weekend sorry um it's called Daisy
Jones in the six and then I googled it
and they're making a show about it and
Camilla maroon is in it oh no I'm pretty
sure she's playing the girl Camilla it's
literally so stunning later when I was
like what reading the book she I was I
see everyone like faceless but just yeah
you know uh what's it called a
silhouette silhouette of them and she
feels did I just give you Ord
she fits the silhouette to a tee I mean
she's so stunning like I'm so excited
for her and her burgeoning career like
she needs to be I'm Riverdale
she's like more elevated than that cuz
she like oh saucers and stuff but I was
just a little of to see came around on
Riverdale Riverdale has been super
elevated did you see Lilly Ryan hot
chick have a girl girl now I did she go
what magazine was it no I saw her on TV
Oh cover girl like oh sorry
cover girl she was in the cover of a
magazine breezy beautiful covergirl I
did I cuz you know I looked up for my TV
last night and I heard like I'm some
like like 90 year old cover there that's
lutely what I thought she's out of a
cover of a magazine therefore she is a
cover girl that's what I thought but she
is a cover girl cover girl and she's
also on the cover of girl yeah she's
killing it I mean she's the face of our
generation I would say yeah I'm excited
for for all of those kids she's like
woke to you know that's why people love
her
yes she's she's everything I'm the sort
let me wait he's John Cena and Shay I
mean if I were Nikki Bella like I would
just be stewing but she does seem really
happy and her and John's relationship
like it was just fraught with peril and
it's not supposed to be that difficult
just because his girls were going
no doesn't mean anything because we said
on the show many times like when you're
rich and you have a lot of jewelry and
like men are buying new jewelry you
leave so many fingers like sometimes you
have to put that jewelry on your ring
finger because you can only have so many
cocktail rings so I don't know if this
necessarily means that they're engaged a
lot Taylor Swift in the documentary
where we spoke about she was wearing an
engagement ring but like it could have
just been like a fancy rich person ring
um it doesn't mean anything like like I
said until I see that was being
exchanged I'm not gonna labor just had a
carnival and she was wearing the ring
and I feel like you pretty much go
jewelry free to the carnival the store
said John Cena was spotted today at a
carnival in Mission Beach San Diego with
che Shara sada right behind him with a
huge engagement ring on her finger
they were very affectionate she was
grabbing on to his arm the whole time
and the ring was deaf on her left hand
damn okay that does sound convincing and
that sounds like the account of someone
who has like their head on straight like
they really did all the investigative
work like they're like they didn't take
a picture they look to see if it was
actually the left hand this is like a
good eye witness yeah I'm believing it
even though they say ah nice view that
eye witnesses are like 0% like eligible
in court like they're appealing they
usually are the worst like retailers of
history I mean if you've seen my cousin
Vinnie you know that right and you could
like literally believe in your soul and
you're not lying that like you saw a
blue car when in reality it was a red
car like eyewitnesses are very
unreliable
according to Marishka Hargitay that's
crazy and I think that everything that
happens on SVU has to be true I think
it's based in truth yeah I don't think
they would go so off-book no I but it's
not crazy like I would be the worst
[ __ ] eyewitness like if I'm ever in a
like a court don't believe anything I
say because I probably really feel like
I did see a yellow car booting me
holiday was totally green color you were
in court like I didn't prosecution put
you up to tell your side like then the
defense would play closer so my god I
saw yellow cocky I always think about
how like if I was ever on trial for like
murder anything like I make so many
crazy jokes on this show like they would
have a lifetime of proof of why I'm a
murderer like I literally said on the
show man a murder multiple people it's
true but just don't murder someone and
then I know by the way I don't play it
off it's still like whether I don't plan
on murdering anyone but there are plenty
people who are on trial or even in jail
for murder who do it like that we may
never leave your house you know because
that's what I'm so gonna be framed for
murder
that's what I'm saying well the
dangerous place toasters
it really is are you ready for our next
story that I just find so interest on um
sure
Hannah Brown reveals she's been on the
wait list
four months for exclusive dating a
pariah okay I have an update to the
story actually that I saw on Twitter
this morning but keep reading okay the
25 year old who stint as ABC's
Bachelorette in 2019 ended in heartbreak
is single and looking to mingle but
despite her celeb status Brown says
she's had to wait like everybody else to
get onto Riya one of the most popular
dating apps for a-listers quote you guys
I don't know if you know this but I was
a Bachelorette and I can't get on Riya
she said on her Instagram story with her
friend I've been waiting I've been on
the waiting list for months now I don't
know it's like being the Bachelorette
makes you like able to cut the line on
Riya there's so many like a real
celebrity like I feel like the real
celebrities they just get on they put
you on the wait list when it's a big fat
no and like maybe if everyone else on
the app died maybe you have a chance oh
yeah but I have heard many times from
multiple people who are incredibly cool
not just like Bachelorette cool like
really rich in famous cool who can't get
on it like you I don't really feel like
sagen plugins their spot but like I've
heard from many people that like there's
no formula I don't think that's so crazy
I dated with requests Anthony Raya it
was based on like how many followers you
have but also the quality of followers
like do cool people follow you right I
did you have BOTS like running around
I'm so Patti Stanger this morning was
tweeting about on this Bachelorette
thing um and she Patti singer must have
been like slighted by Riya because she
like keeps tweeting about them and she
was tweeting that Stassi got kicked off
of Riya but I'm sure that's because
she's engaged um no you get kicked off
if you're if you talk about riot
publicly it was it true yeah you're not
it's like Fight Club like you can't talk
about it so obviously Hannah Brown is
never getting on at this point but
bragging when like I know Amanda Stanton
when she was on bachelor in paradise she
talked about Riya but she said celebrity
dating app she wouldn't say Riya because
that's how you get kicked off got it so
Patti singers like on a mission against
Riya because they only let in men and
she's like tweeting up a storm like riot
is a big deal frankly it's the same ten
guys over and over again they don't want
to get new people I want to create an
app so women can take quality men like
she's obviously thirsting out for it but
I thought it was interesting that she
said Stassi got kicked off but I thought
she probably got kicked off because she
was engaged like I feel like I feel like
she probably talked about it maybe I
don't know but that's it's like yes roll
that's the vibe I've gotten got it well
this is not the first time I've heard of
someone cool
getting weight listed on Raya and I
think had I browned just ensured that
she'll never get on Raya yeah cuz now
everyone's talking about it must be hard
like what is she gonna do go on any
other and heating app like no she can't
go on apps even by the way even Riya
when you get on I don't really know
anyone who successfully met on Ryan like
whenever I'm with someone who's on right
I like beg them to let me swipe on it
and first of all I never see anyone
cause you know one couple that matter
right yeah I'll tell I don't know if
they like have publicly said okay tell
me later but yeah they're cute couple
that's interesting well that's the first
I've heard of it so Hannah brown you're
fine like go to a bar go to stagecoach
job but I'm glad she's ready to start
dating again I think it's time it's
definitely time I think that she has a
very full life but I think she's missing
having someone to share it with and I
think that's something that just the bad
that I get is that that's something
that's important to her it's important
to me too yeah it's okay to the sassy
did talk about it on her podcast a lot
and that's why she got kicked off oh
shut the [ __ ] up some people are saying
in the home yes yeah into her son he's
not mo happy for her this I'm glad that
we're both married and we never have to
worry about getting on riot cuz we've
spoken about it so much today right she
found her chef boyardee
beau Artie he asked you that was really
cute and I like to think in her hair
that she were around her apartment uh
the pony he I was like a bow yeah
everyone was looking snatch alert last
night not matter pumper all agree the
hundred four sometimes it's not like
that no but sometimes it's the opposite
right it's nothing of the sort so I
really appreciated the looks that were
being served
obviously by law I can't of course she
brings in every episode I loved seeing
Danis butt cheeks when she got into bed
and a song I know but it was a really
weird scene and it was very staged it
was really awful full makeup like
wearing their street clothes into the
bed it was weird the cameras are there
watching them cuddle it must have been
like 6:00 p.m. I truly can't and they're
pretending they're going to sleep yeah
like who's gonna lock the door behind
the camera man so true
there's gonna be a break-in exactly Jed
okay we're gonna recap veteran pearls at
the end okay next up Megan and Harry
reportedly are barred from using Sussex
royal label going forward this is a big
deal we knew this was coming
Megan and Prince Harry will be moving
forward in their new life without a
valuable part of their brand with the
Queen and other senior palace officials
reportedly not confirmed yet reportedly
agreeing that the couple will no longer
be able to keep the word royal as part
of their brand but even the word royal
yes so according to the Daily Mail that
you had hope to leverage Sussex royal
into not just a new website but a global
trademark for a range of items and
activities including clothing stationery
books and teaching materials and a new
charitable organization with the name
the pair began using the term in early
2019 after their branch off from Prince
William and Kate Middleton's household
Kensington Royal so we have reported
that they did all of these trademarks
for Sussex Royal that we're just gonna
like be bringing in the cash apparently
they reportedly allegedly the queen is
gonna bar them from using that
so those trademarks would be useless
useless I totally understand like why
they would want the trademark for like
philanthropic organizations TV shows
like what the hell kind of clothing
company you're gonna start Sussex Royal
what its gonna be like pantsuits no but
like merch they're not gonna make merch
like with their logo on it yes they will
I don't think so
but maybe ever talk about how much press
we got when Simon came on the show
talking about how he's gotten like
hundreds of million dollars and deal
offers for Megan mark oh yeah that was
crazy
that was crazy and really fascinated to
hear from someone in the industry I mean
if I was Megan Markel here's what I
would do I would um sign of gel with
Netflix signed it's signed 100% yeah let
you know that for sure yeah that's what
everyone's saying they have a deal with
Netflix I don't know like I don't know
maybe the paperwork's taking awhile but
so I wanted to hundred million dollars
ten episodes doc you serious about like
some philanthropic [ __ ] that I do like
animals or whatever then I would take
that hundred million dollars put 75 of
it in a mutual fund that like grows
interest year to year and take that 25
mil buy a nice house sit relax enjoy
maybe I'd shoot a Chanel campaign every
few years just like you know to grow
trust fund for Archie but I think that's
that nice yeah chanela Netflix what else
do you need
not much I mean her face would be like
all over airports and duty-free like
with the Chanel logo and I think they'll
be chic totally she really is like a
global artists she's a global icon
she should be in airports I don't vote
say icon she's a global person people
know her globally she's an icon okay I
guess I look so jealous of her you know
yeah I just I'm so excited to see what
she does next because like I feel like
we all want to be a princess and then I
think any of us were like and if I were
a princess I would renounce it you know
I don't we all want to be a princess but
I don't think a lot of us want to be an
X princess yeah but she does so I'm
curious to see where this journey leads
her we've just been like guessing what
she's gonna do now for so many like
months I just do it like I need to know
well she they can't look too
you know yeah uh a also to pay back that
three million dollars for the comment
that they took please chump change do
one sponsored post uh I'm sure this will
be a setback for them this sussex royal
stuff yeah but the grand scheme of
things not a big deal no because they're
still famous and well-connected whether
or not we can call them the duchess yeah
and they can sell stationery yeah which
I think was tacky move anyway so
honestly the Queen is just really like
protecting them from be so protecting
the Queenie vibes brand yeah and
honestly and in turn protecting them
from being like shady sellouts yeah
making their own stationery and merch
selling you're not Shopify if you don't
know what they would have speaking of
merch twelve o'clock p.m. st. Patty's
Day morning toast merch kiss me I'm
toasty so if I can cute I'm wearing an
extra-large I should have gotten a large
so if you want to live like mine I would
say large yeah bye bye Jax especially
because in the summer like I don't wear
pants but in the so I have to do an
extra large so that I can cover my thumb
but if I'm wearing leggings or tights
which I'm wearing today is tights I
would do a large so you could see a
little bum I love oh you've been hanging
out with reg Mary Mary and Meaghan too
much
you wouldn't get Harry to make my bub I
read too many books that are based in
London I was that was that I read there
in London and she's like now I know all
these words speaking of London the Brits
were last night and GDC Harry Styles
showed up he was wearing a little black
ribbon a lot of people thought it was a
tribute to Caroline Fleming said her
last name Caroline Flack Caroline
Fleming is from what ladies London and a
far-off you know Caroline Flack and I
posted it on our Instagram without even
knowing that they used to date Harry
Styles and Caroline Flack is that cute
like you know what I mean
that's really sweet full circle oh I
didn't have this as a story but Harry
Styles was was robbed at that point he
has had a wig he has had a week that's
crazy
mm-hmm that just when things like that
happened it really makes you realize how
like celebrities are celebrities but
they're really just people like anyone
get robbed yeah and they're vulnerable
yeah probably more vulnerable than we
are cuz everyone knows they're rich yeah
look if I see what passed me on the
street like no one's gonna think I'm
rich like I'm wearing like leggings from
ASOS you know what I mean like I don't
know I've got billion also my sweaters
from XLE I got it for free XLE my lord
Elizabeth it's really cute I didn't get
that sweater yeah you did no I didn't
know myself are you sure yeah I saw two
I got super cute sub and she's making
some really cute cardigans which is my
vibe
for the spring I love an oversized
cardigan and this is from the new xle
job and you know Margaret an item and
XLE named after her the Margaux cardigan
I know and it's like I'm happy for her
know that I am but like we're jealous
like where's ours like if you were gonna
make an item called the Jackie Lauren
Elizabeth like what would it be yeah and
I actually think Lauren already has an
item names of the Claudia because she
names items after her friends and she
has a friend who I think is a better
friend than me names Claudia so loose
gain I think your time is coming she'll
probably do like the the girl maybe the
girl item oh my god I cannot I hate
being referred to girl referred to as
girl with no job I know I just feel like
I'm not her anymore but I am yeah you'll
always be her that's all you're ever
gonna be stop this show me I'm sorry I
need to continue there you can take me
out of the country but you can save the
kanji and we know I love that song so
sorry I didn't just mean - like blurt
that out yeah it was like you're never
gonna be anything more it was just him
sorry okay next story ready
of course Ben Affleck calls his divorce
from Jennifer Garner quote the biggest
regret of my life good oMG wait I
haven't talked about Ben Affleck or even
thought about him in so long well he's
spreading he's bearing all for the New
York Times [ __ ] about his crumbling
marriage which prompted his relapse into
alcohol abuse and the rehab stint that
follows so he's just opening up about
his life is he still with the nanny I
don't think so I don't know because
eating that SNL producer for a while
that's what I mean he was on riah
remember we reported that he probably
got kicked off so I think he's probably
dating but no one in particular
quote I drink relatively normally for a
long time what happened was that I
started drinking more and more when my
marriage was falling apart
this was 2015 2016 my drinking of course
created more marital problems the
biggest regret of my life is this
divorce he continued shame is really
toxic there is no positive byproduct of
shame it's just doing in a toxic toxic
hideous feeling of low self-worth and
self-loathing
this is really sad I mean of course you
would regret divorcing Jennifer Garner
she's literally the most precious woman
in the world and they have a million
kids together so that's like his family
this is sad you know I've been hearing a
lot and it's Ben Affleck and I've heard
Chrissy Teigen talk about it a lot John
Mayer talking about a lot and I was just
waiting
it cuz it started Jessica Simpson's
memoir about how like celebrities say
they don't start out alcoholics like
they just start out drinking and then it
spirals so much and like little things
in their life like make them drink like
a little bit more like a little bit
earlier and then all of a sudden they're
just like drinking so much I feel like
I'm like getting there like I really do
know yeah I feel like I'm drinking too
much I feel like there were times when I
used to drink yeah like I was drinking
too much but it's just I think there's a
big there's a difference yeah I think
also I mean we were just talking about
charting but like when you're drinking
during the day like in Jessica Simpson's
book when she was like she always had
like a glitter Cup with all of her when
she was like go pick up her kids at
school like crazy [ __ ] that's when you
know it's like getting to a point but I
just think it's so interesting how so
many celebrities are becoming self-aware
enough and are really I've been hearing
like more now more than ever more
celebrities becoming sober which i think
is great yeah it's like in this book I
read
JC Jones on 6 where she's like drinks
and and tells a lot of drugs to mask the
pain but then also at a certain point
like drugs and alcohol make everything
more emotional more heightened and when
you do away and you're just left with
the problem it's sometimes like it just
it accelerates everything
yeah but then it's like if you're
drinking just to party and then like
you're the last one at the party that's
when you know it's also time to stop you
know the oldest person at the party yeah
I've gone home I don't see age like on
this show yeah I watched an episode of
shark tank yesterday go to an old one
and there was one pitch I don't know
what your is for him but the Sharks
looked different so it was old uh-huh
and it was like it brought me to tears
was it a man the oilerie was a only came
in at the end of the pitch was he's like
a really really cute older man yeah and
he had an oil about like the company was
um the did put in retail stores it was
like oil we watching on CNBC yeah me Joe
and it was before Vanderpump rules let's
pause and meet our mics for this siren
that goes by I hope everyone's okay
we're good okay this Shark Tank episode
yes this company called called the
oilerie where it's basically like an oil
bar bar full of olive oils where you can
taste different olive oils in like
because usually you just buy extra
virgin olive oil at the store but it's
really a sensory experience yeah I saw
the episode oh my god and I was crying
to it when the he didn't get a deal I
mean he jumped into his wife's arms and
he left he was so strong throughout he's
such a good pitcher was a really good
idea they loved to em are like loved him
but no one could really help him except
mr. wonderful who was being too much of
a snob to like I go for this concept
right like saying how many workers would
never go for this and he's only had
success cuz he goes to like [ __ ] places
that were tainted olive oil that's when
Shark Tank is like a little um it's
getting too big for its own bridges
because a lot of these investors they
can't relate to like these regular
people problems because they have enough
to change their own socks in ten years
so they don't know that you need a sock
changing device you know like they're
just not real people and I think
sometimes it hinders them from really
understanding how good a product could
be and that's frustrating totally so the
Sharks respected him and he he and he
had really built something like
something great and he had been through
like so many financial issues in the
past and like he's like water being
turned off his electricity being turned
by god I loved God and he didn't get a
deal and he was so polite and then he
left and he started crying and then I
was crying but Mark said something
really really nice to him at the end he
was like we call a lot of people on the
show shark tank gold diggers cuz they
come in the show with no intention of
actually getting a deal but they just
want the exposure that this show gives
them and like it's frustrating for us
for people who like aren't actually here
for the right reasons and he was like
you're literally the opposite of that
like you're gonna come out here and get
so much exposure and I'm so happy for
that and I want you but like I actually
can't help you it was so sad I actually
turned it on literally the exact same
time it was so turn it off after that it
was just like geez too much for me
literally me too Wow and then I started
watching The Biggest Loser which is I
cannot explain how excited I am that the
biggest losers back on TV me and Olivia
used to watch that show every single
week when it was on NBC and you would
just cry and cry and cry and now it's
back on USA which I think is a perfect
fit for it and they found such cute
people like I'm loving it but you know
when I think about the formula of the TV
show it's kind of [ __ ] up that they
send people home every week because
those people are really there to like
get better and I guess it keeps them
like trying their hardest because the
idea of going home and not
being able to lose more weight like with
the help of the trainers and the fitness
and whatever it sucks but like it just
kind of sucks like these people are
really a lot of them are I'm like the
brink of death like they tell them all
their medical conditions and then they
send them home like if they're if they
lose the least like the fact that
someone goes home every week is like
kind of [ __ ] up should be able to go
somewhere where they're not on the show
but they can continue their journey or
it's like a you know like Big Brother
how they keep you but it's like a
halfway yeah but so what they meet you
is that there's a there's $100,000 prize
for whoever wins but then there's an
at-home prize so you're supposed to go
home and keep at it and you can win
25,000 as opposed I think the hundred
thousand that you win if you stay and
make it all the way that's great yeah it
is but like every time they send someone
home it's like everyone cries because
they don't want this person to go home
obviously because they like them but
more so because like they need to be
here yeah so who's like making me sad
the show yeah that's like um you know a
flaw in the system yeah and so Bob who
was one of the old trainers is now the
host of it and they have two new like
Instagram trainers and the Instagram
trainers like have their own storyline
and honestly like I'm just not here for
it it's like the worst part of the show
they're like they're like twenty five
thirty and they're like crying when it's
just like it's not about you girlfriend
like go back to the contestants like
they're so interesting yeah that's like
when they make Project Runway about the
models but it's just not that's that's a
perfect analogy Jackie okay I just want
to say major shadow to Biggest Loser I'm
so glad it's back then final story is
something that I think is so exciting
Disney has unveiled a fairy tale wedding
dress collection is Cinderella Castle at
Walt Disney Resort oh my god a kimbley
Britney and Jax are already married
because this is literally made for her I
know Disney has launched a fairy tale
wedding dress collection with gowns
inspired by princess characters from
various Disney classics including The
Little Mermaid Beauty and the Beast in
Cinderella the Cinderella Castle a Walt
Disney Resort in Orlando will also
receive a royal makeover in honor of the
film's 70th anniversary the Disney
fairytale weddings collection created in
collaboration with Allure Bridals
features a total of 16 wedding gown
styles in different silhouettes and
fabrics the designs all capture quote
the style and spirit of Disney Princess
characters such as Ariel
Aurora Belle jasmine Cinderella
Pocahontas Rapunzel Tiana and Snow White
according to a statement from allure
Brides I mean this is literally the
cutest thing ever I can't believe that
no one has thought of this before I
think this is
gonna be very successful and like so
sweet like every girls like want to be
princess at my wedding and like now you
can living at a princess wedding dress
totally they'll be priced from $3,500 to
$10,000 and available exclusively
available exclusively at Kleinfeld
Bridal oh my god what a great
partnership this is so exciting I'm like
mad that I'm already married yeah this
is I just we should go try them on oh my
god totally great also um they should if
they're gonna do like an influencer
campaign it's like promote these dresses
they should really have Britney they
should but right yeah it's already
married it's already married so we need
like an engaged princess yeah Meghan
mark what a cute idea I love with like
Brad's just like do good stuff it's so
rare like I was someone at the company
has a good idea and has like a good head
on their shoulders and like get
something I feel like in these big
companies like good ideas come and go
but like they never actually get me this
is so adorable
I'm loving the Kleinfeld partnership I
think this is so sweet I'm pretty sure
they're gonna debut at New York fashion
bridal week I would love to be invited
yeah maybe since this episode will be
invited and this is something we'll say
yes to if if someone wants to invite us
of course also this is making me
remember my Marin Disney did that
weddings thing hosted by Lauren and Ben
yes it was like a TV show showing like
the most amazing weddings that had ever
been done
aunt is at Disney World and it was
hosted by Ben and Lauren like when they
were breaking up Lauren Bruce Gellin Ben
Higgins that was like iconic yeah that
really was they were perfect for that
show though until they broke up yeah I
always forget that they were together
because they're both like so happy in
their own lives and I feel like they
really had an amicable breakup yeah
that's like so happy for both of them
yeah it's ideal oh you know what I was
talking to snitch yesterday about The
Bachelor cuz she wanted to know my
thoughts on the episode because
obviously she can't be bothered to watch
the toes so I was telling her what this
and then we were talking about who we
think was gonna be the Bachelorette and
I was like I think it should be Kelly or
maybe Kelsey and she was like yeah but I
don't think they're gonna do someone
from the season she was saying what you
were saying she said they're gonna go
back for sure there's this theory that
we're gonna get our Eid yes and I came
up with who should be the Bachelorette I
cannot wait you were so good at
predicting stuff I took everything into
consideration and I think that it should
be
Amanda Stanton oh I've seen a bunch of
theories about that and I mean I think
that's great there's no one more ready
for love and she's been through The
Bachelor ringer like she's
thirsty and that she has no time for
people who are thirsty like this would
be a great way for the franchise to get
back on track of like people actually
looking for love yes and she is popping
on social media like she's you know
everything of the sort everything of the
sort so she feels that oh I would buy
that but also like she is someone
looking for love wanting to take this
seriously and I also think like she
would have to be convinced to do it cuz
I'm not certain that she would even
wanted you know I don't think she would
be the perfect choice because she comes
from like the glory days of The Bachelor
which was like Ben Higgins season a
cotillion everyone loves her everyone's
rooting for her she would take it so
seriously and I think he would it would
hit every every point I think that's
such a good idea and then selfishly like
we are friends with The Bachelor right
so maybe she'll have it like a date
where all of her friends can enjoy guys
oh my god love that for us I've had
really good prediction a lot of people
are saying that we're gonna go back into
the archives and I'm here for it even
though I would love to see Kelsey or
Kelly I do think we are past the glory
days of The Bachelor and in an attempt
to recreate that they might go back yeah
but then I sometimes think we're in the
glory days of The Bachelor like it's
everywhere it's you know top of mind
like Tyler see dating Gigi Hadid like
yeah it's bigger than this but it always
feels like the past is the glory days
and you never can realize you're in the
glory days until the glory until now is
the past do you know anyway I think
we're in it Tammy Lovato Mike Johnson oh
my god that was so weird
should we do your toes just first or
Vanderpump rules here toasters okay we
had a new episode of Vanderpump rules
post pride everyone is hungover I there
was a lot that happened and I want to
get into obviously all like the canceled
culture stuff but I just have to say one
of my favorite conversations was the
conversation between Dana and Ariana at
the bar where they both are talking
about how their bye and then they're
just like bye-bye
I thought that was really cute and I
think E I just live for Dana and I love
how she didn't like make it a huge thing
she just like came out and sermon like
also told max you know yeah I'm bi yeah
I like when Tina walked up to the bar I
was like oh I feel like these two would
be friends yeah and then they just had
such a fun conversation and they you
know just keeps winning everyone over so
easily and like that's how it should be
like even when she was talking to Jax
last week when she was talking to Stassi
and Katie that was the best part of the
episode and you know they're so hard on
everyone they don't want to like
everyone and they're so mean to new
people
she's just so likable there's nothing
you can't like which is why it makes me
question scheana so hard that she
immediately disliked her yeah it's
it's it's just jealousy we went through
okay let's talk about the pastor the
sequence of events according to the cast
so far is that now when was their
wedding June June okay so in December
people had found their pastors remarks
posted a few of them on Instagram we're
tagging Jackson Britney everyone saw it
no one really spoke about it and
according to Jackson Britney they called
up the pastor and was like what the [ __ ]
is this that's confirmed because we saw
it on watch what happens live oh yeah
she gives everything a lot of really
good conducts true and the timeline is
there yeah so they call up the pastor
and they're like what the [ __ ] the
pastor is someone who is from Kentucky
Brittany grew up with his very close
with his family including his daughters
they called him up and were like what is
this and the guy explained it and made
it seem like it was nothing and that it
wasn't true and he doesn't feel that way
right and Brittany and Jax didn't feel
the need to investigate it further
because they take him at his word it's
Brittany's family friend and people
continued till I tagged them and stuff
but they had already spoken to it and
they felt comfortable knowing that this
man didn't really feel that way if you
know if you don't watch Vanderpump rules
essentially what happened was the pastor
who was supposed to marry Jackson
Britney is from Kentucky very very like
old-school conservative Bible Belt
people had found like his facebook posts
saying that like gay people should burn
in hell like really horrible stuff
saying that he a child can choose their
gender just like really homophobic like
not okay stuff these days like you just
can't [ __ ] say that chip right okay
and so he had all these posts people
were fighting like Bravo fan accounts
were like finding it on Instagram
posting it tagging them tagging everyone
in the cast but Brittany and Jax saw it
at first addressed it thought they were
fine continue to see the post but
ignored it because they felt like it was
yeah it was fine and it was not true
anything taken kalim of posts at what
they first saw when they called him was
like one post they said versus when it
all two weeks before the wedding when
they dealt with it it was multiple posts
so then two weeks before the wedding
even more posts came out Lisa Vanderpump
saw called Brittany and Jackson they
were like yet we know we we have to do
something about it so they ended up
firing him which I'm sure was really
awkward for Brittany like she's friends
with their his kids like it's easy for
us to me like cancel the pastor but I
got the end of the day like he's a
family and like she was friends with his
family like how [ __ ] awkward they all
grew up together like at the end of the
day this is also like people having to
socially interact with other people and
it's [ __ ] awkward I'm certainly
wanted to avoid this conversation at all
cost and we actually see that they ended
up doing
via text which is like the greatest way
they get out of an awkward situation if
you hate to say it on the phone oh my
god I would have died like so awkward
yeah just let him know like don't show
up right so they they cancelled the
pastor and this was the day before
Brittany's Brittany bridal shower so
they had the bridal shower Brittany like
really didn't want to talk about it
because she's very hell-bent on her
special time not being interrupted with
anything other than happiness for her
and Jackson whether that deals with the
pastor or her and Jax's past it she just
does not want to be inundated she's like
happy to have her head in the clouds and
not be talking about anything that's
negative whether it is about the pastor
whether it's about faith like she just
doesn't want any of that [ __ ]
yeah which is understandable but a lot
of the girls I think we're getting
frustrated with her like come back down
to earth like there's stuff going on
down here yeah they they cancelled the
pastor everyone Lala Ariana a lot of the
girls were like annoyed at first that
like they weren't doing anything but
then they did the right thing and
everyone was like okay good
but for some reason Sandoval and Ariana
like wouldn't get past the fact that it
took like if it were then they would
have handled it differently and they
would have handled it even faster than
Jackson we did that it took Lisa calling
them for them to do something about it
so when they're all at Peter's birthday
Santa Ball and Ariana are talking about
it they pull Santa ball pulls Jax over
and it's like why did it take Lucia and
Jax just gets up immediately and has no
time for it because I'm sure was really
frustrating to like be in a situation
where a lot of people are assuming that
Jax and Brittany might be homophobic
because someone they know is homophobic
and like you can't blame someone for
what someone else does or says like
that's just not and I think also what we
lose in watching the show is the context
of like the whole world is like
inundated em and so it's not just the
conversation going on with their friends
and they don't want to talk about it's
like they're dealing with this on a much
bigger scale
and their friends should have their back
and by the time Tom Sandoval says
something to Jax it's a red even that
wasn't handled and they did the right
thing and so why are you bringing it up
again and it's like in that moment like
Tom Sandoval was trying to make them
look bad like Stassi said it's like
trying to cancel them yeah I had and and
Tom Sandoval had said for months they
were seeing all these things why isn't
Jackson Britney doing something and that
was the time to say something complete
or what it did she ways yeah and no it's
it's not even too late like it's done
it's over like there was months long
period where you could have like had
your time to say something which by the
way you would have had every right to
say something worse but now you're
saying it when it's already been handled
and now we're on camera just seems like
their intention
100% pure like if they're genuinely like
upset like our Nana is a member of the
lgbtq+ community like she has every
right to be upset and offended by what
the pastor said but to me like the
timing of them coming for Jackson
Britney just doesn't seem like they're
genuinely like mad and want to help you
know heal the community it seems like
they're just trying to make them look
bad
yeah and so I I did understand why
Jackson Britney got so heated because
also friends don't do that and you know
what if they were friends they would
have pulled them aside earlier been like
hey we Cena seems like you should do
something even though they weren't
filming at that time like that's what
you do as a front right so coming on
when the timing doesn't make sense and
coming for them on camera just makes it
seem like their intentions weren't
genuine in wanting to like teach Jax and
Brittany or explain or make the
situation better I just didn't think
that it was genuine and I'm kind of I'm
really glad all the girls had Britney's
back because Britney like okay I never
would seek things on Twitter people
thinking Jackson Bernier homophobic like
okay Jax definitely says [ __ ] that's
crazy all the time but like there's
literally no way they're homophobic they
live in West Hollywood and Jack I mean
like Britney's best friend Zach he's gay
like it just it makes no sense and I
just think that to hold someone
accountable for what someone they're
they know does or says is is it very
dangerous spiral like that's just not
you you can only be responsible for what
you do and what you say yeah and I think
they did the right thing they'd only he
didn't earlier and didn't just believe
what the pastor said in December sure
but whatever yeah but like Jack said
like he's the past if he didn't think
they he wouldn't lie they get him jack
is like it's a pastor he's it was all
very gently like genuinely like naive of
them to me that he's a pastor what do
you mean like he's always gonna say the
right thing you know yeah so of course
if I if it were me but I've handled it
differently yes do I fault them for
handling it the way that they did know
they ended up doing the right thing now
they get Lance Bass to officiate their
wedding and I think it's fine I think
it's fine also the best part about this
episode was that it was titled it's not
about the pastor shut up oh my god
whoever came up but that is a genius
genius genius do anything else happened
in the episode Petersburg the party
actually looked really fun nobody
remembered that scheana was freezing her
eyes and that was so circle when they
did a clip of all the time she's told
people and have nobody [ __ ] remembers
she no it's not in the episode once
until Jax until Britney said Lance Bass
is marrying I say macchina pops out out
of North if you give a thing that was
actually really funny yeah it's just my
shameless machinima has really become
insufferable I agree
insufferable and it's hard for me
because I have started to
like Ariana's so much in the beginning
of the show I didn't really like cling
to her um or like relate to her at all
but now I just think she's like funny
and genuine and I actually really like
her and she's smart like smarter than a
lot of the cat so her cat her commentary
on what's going on is always really
poignant but when it comes to Tom
Sandoval's she obviously always takes
his side so he stand a supportive
girlfriend but he's always wrong
literally always yeah but I like she
just has to defend her man and I
appreciate that but I think if they
weren't dating she wouldn't defend him
like I don't think she actually agrees
with him yeah but that's part of that
she's in a relationship and she wants to
be a united front I respect that I think
she agreed with him this episode about
the Jackson Britney stuff and even when
he went to say something after the fact
like I think she felt like that was the
right thing to do I feel like maybe last
episode the stuff with Stassi but she's
weird about stassi's book there's
definitely some competition there
because they both and were writing books
at the same time we've been hearing
about the cocktail book for multiple
seasons
yeah and ended up coming out like a few
months after stassi's book stassi's book
was a New York Times bestseller I don't
think that Tom and Ariana's was so maybe
there was like a little competitiveness
there because there is weirdness when it
comes to the book yes so I think in last
week she I don't I don't know how she
felt about it
uh what else was there um just Jana like
literally being the apple of my eye you
know apple of my eye that's how I feel
about Lala like showing up serving looks
I can't when she came in her visor her
Mimi visor when beau made her champagne
free Aperol spritz like it was so cute
so like so sweet I like I just and I
feel like this this was actually really
good episode mostly because they were
talking about some like really heavy
topics but it also was a good episode in
the way that it integrated the old the
old guard and the new Oh Jackson I mean
though I'd okay me and Raquel oh my god
that was a really sad scene that was but
like call me crazy like it's Peter a
loser like why the yes by the way yeah
because even when Jax heard that Peter
didn't invite James for Jax's sake
Jax is like I'm never gonna tell you who
not to win my tier party like a few
years ago I feel like Jackson James
couldn't be in the same room but like I
don't even think of them anymore I don't
think of them at O it was kind of weird
for he like John in by James cuz you're
not friends with him not because you
think it's the right thing to do because
you're Jax's groomsmen and Jax doesn't
like James it's not like James and Jax
would have like gone into a fight they
had to be held back like they're just
hot friends but who cares
ya know it's not like it used to be like
they're just not really that close this
story
line of like Raquel maybe being
suspended I just I'm so dumb it's gonna
be a no friend no relationship is so
toxic I've never seen two people I've
never seen a man who has lost respect
for his girlfriend in his life like it's
it's hard really made me really sad and
it's like I have no respect for him
because he's so me to his girlfriend but
I wasn't nervous back for her like stand
up for yourself [ __ ] yeah but she can't
like he just said he just tears her down
every deer in headlights
totally but every conversation he's just
tearing her down the dumbest Inc I'm not
gonna tell you not to go
well he's literally telling her not to
go yeah thanks Adam okay well great
episode love enterpreneurs let's jump
into deer toasters which is our weekly
and by segments we do it every Wednesday
if you are new here and you want to
write us an email email us at Deer
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous and we like to talk about what
you need us to talk about you need
advice on girlfriend/boyfriend whatever
let us know the weirder the better so
let's jump right in
I'd be new cards so like I'm really
excited about these cards okay number
one your toasters we have two sisters
writing to you two sisters and we have a
crisis on our hands how do you tell your
best friends that they have a mustache
we love our friends but they are of the
sensitive breed we don't want to hurt
anyone's feelings but we can't and
shan't look at them anymore how do you
tell your gal pals to get a razor or a
wax we love you xoxo we've actually had
this before but that one was with a
co-worker which is very different very
different so my my go-to is always hey
I'm running getting lip waxed want to
come and like you if they say no be like
you should come okay that's it that's
interesting what I do is I'll always
turn the situation on myself I'd be like
what's her name Sally Sally Black's like
I feel like Annie run I haven't got one
in a while make her get all up there and
talk about her like I hate my mustache
like it makes me so subconscious
and I just wax it like even though it's
painful and it takes a lot of time like
I just sing it's something I should do
like to talk about it for yourself a lot
and like maybe she'll realize like maybe
it's something that she should maybe
she'll be like do you need wine right
cuz when you're like driving my teeth
and you say no and then you always say
do I have something you might eat so
it's like twelve months - no - I have a
mustache I think it's like a natural
human reaction to guess about the same
thing you know yeah yeah maybe or you
could write a letter that says like dear
Sam oh this is a tough thing because
like people are weird about body hair
you know some people would like to grow
it out they think it's empowering as a
feminist thing but mustaches are
different ya know but also like this
person's your friend you would know if
this was a statement that they were
making you know yeah they would like
that's something you would talk about
should be like
I don't like that would be part of her
ethos like yeah you would know that
about her
totally like if she has hairy armpits
then you know she's gonna grout her
mustache she probably talked about her
right to be like I feel empowered all
right next up dear toasters please help
me solve the mystery that is my best
friend's deep dark secret let's start
with some background I've had an amazing
group of girlfriends since middle school
okay we've known each other for 15 years
needless to say we've been through
everything and have shared most almost
everything with each other until
recently we've also started we've also
stayed pretty close to lots of friends
from middle school in high school I even
married a guy from a town over now to
the mystery one of the girls in our girl
group let's call her Donna recently
started dating my husband's best friend
let's call him John they've always had a
weird relationship but seemingly seemed
perfect for each other
now one random day the group chat gets a
text from Donna saying she broke it off
with John and she can't tell us why she
said do not ask me about this it's
something between the two of us that we
are not speaking about okay fine I
totally understand keeping a personal
but now every time every day since the
both of them have been moping around and
gets super weird and defensive if anyone
even brings up relationships now she's
asking for advice as to what to do but
won't tell us the mysterious secret what
the actual [ __ ] do we keep trying to
figure this out how do we even respond
without knowing also what the [ __ ] could
it be please help hashtag the power of
the toast I would just be like straight
up I can't help you if I don't know the
details you want something for me I just
I need something for me like I would
love to help you I need even not the
whole story
I need the gist what's the topic like
what do you think it is I have no idea
people like people are weird like I kind
of have like a really morbid idea what I
feel like no I don't to say that's like
so [ __ ] up okay I feel like maybe like
he like hit her or something you know oh
and like it's I was a she had to leave
but like she does wanna like embarrass
him for like being a woman music like
that's the vibe I get like what could
eat something so weird that you wouldn't
or batterer embarrassing that you
wouldn't tell your girlfriend's why he
broke up with your boyfriend like even
if he cheated like that happens you know
yeah I don't maybe and it's like so more
but for my mind to go there but that is
where it went when I was reading it
interesting well if that's the case then
you definitely should try and get it out
of her because she needs someone to talk
to
yeah but good for her for bouncing
mm-hmm did you have a lady's third and
final collodion Jackie I've been having
a lot of anxiety about the situation
recently so I'm writing this attempt for
advice and help I nanny for a family for
the past two years I absolutely love
them were like a family now
so house it for them when they travel
which is almost once every two months so
they can go visit their grandparents in
Florida however one of the kids just
slipped to me that there are cameras
throughout the house and even showed me
them oh my god
at first they thought this is sign
because I do nothing wrong however
thinking about it more there's a big
issue when the family travels my
boyfriend stays with me at their house
because I get scared being alone the
family knows this and they're fine with
it however my boyfriend and I have had
sex many times while house-sitting over
the past two years do they have a sex
tape of me when would they have watched
it although I love his family many
people including my friends and family
have mentioned to me that the father
acts very flirty towards need due to
comments he makes I personally have
never thought that way and always told
people they were crazy however now that
I realized that it's possible that this
family is a video of me having sex I'm
nervous about the father watching it due
to how many people have said that he
tries flirting with me I'd been sick to
my stomach for days I can't eat or sleep
I feel violated I don't know what to do
help Oh honestly I feel like you're like
literally this whole situations in your
head like I feel like you've a nice
thing going with the family like don't
[ __ ] it up stop having sex with your
boyfriend the one night thing you drew
that you house an okay you can have sex
in your own house and just I the dad is
just being friendly like to me like this
is us like making a mountain out of a
molehill it seems like a good situation
like you have a good thing going aside
from the dad making her uncomfortable I
feel like this is a very doable thing
she wasn't uncomfortable until people
are like isn't he weird and she's like
maybe but she didn't feel uncomfortable
okay so he was being friendly to have a
good thing aside from that element I
actually feel like that's a very real
thing like even when you say at an
Airbnb sometimes like the yes the home
will have cameras even if they're
outside like if it's a nice you know
vacation house like you might have sex
like outside by the pool like and they
will have footage of you having sex I
don't think that people who have cameras
in their home unless they're like really
[ __ ] creepy they don't watch the
footage unless something happens that
requires them to go back and get footage
like if there's a break-in something
goes missing so I don't think the family
watches this footage but if it does give
you a pit then just don't have sex there
anymore javi I thought the same thing
because this weekend me and Marco stayed
at TP G's apartment in Miami if you're
not having sex like you walk around the
house naked
obviously right I was walking around
without pants and I was like there's a
camera because I'm like and we weren't
even staying in his bedroom you're
staying in the guest bedroom but I was
just think I'm like I'm gonna put on
pants because like there might be a
camera and I think that's something that
a lot of people struggle with especially
when
comes to Airbnb and so my advice to this
girl would be they're definitely not
watching you have attacks like but do
stop having sex like now that you know
the camera if it worries you yeah I
don't think there was a camera in your
bedroom so if you're having sex on the
couch you shouldn't be doing that anyway
in someone else's house like have sex in
the bedroom that they gave you because
there's definitely no cameras in their
butts up having sex where their kids
like lie around and play with their toys
so one has text on someone's couch
agreed like that is egregious so stop
having sex in public places and I think
if you felt fine with the dad before
like don't make this something that it
might not be but just like if it's
giving you a feeling in your stomach
like use that going forward to not
continue to put yourself in a situation
where you were feeling uncomfortable
keep within the back of your head but
just move forward I think you've a nice
thing going like don't [ __ ] it up yeah
like many things are making you crazy a
lot of people inadvertently like have
sex tapes because you know with nest and
varying and there's cameras everywhere
VCS and they're not like you know the
old school like oh we need to install
the rumor it's like you have your servo
camera right yeah so and sometimes that
will get a spray tan in your house yeah
in your living room and of my tits on
your camera no the turbo is like so
troublesome like when Theo was a baby we
used to keep the fur bow in our room and
like literally every night I have to
turn it around like you don't even think
I'm like maybe every now and then maybe
I've forgotten like there's a sex tape
of me somewhere but like job cameras
these days there are cameras everywhere
like it's not that crazy that there
might be photos of you having sex
somewhere also when we were in Atlantic
City we were walking back to the hotel
and we were wasted and I flashed my
titties to been in the hallway and if
anybody ever wants to ruin my life they
could find that footage
why I feel like that was exactly what
you need right now I'm like saying it it
was yeah but if anyone was a finally
like I'd be totally okay with that um
all right well thanks that was a good
advice that was an interesting one oh
dear toasters at gmail.com our emails
are up and we'll always keep it
anonymous if you've any questions for us
feel free to just hop on in slide into
our dm's okay mm-hmm anything else
before we let everyone go merch is
dropping at noon Eastern Time the shot
morning toast calm singer Patti special
pre-order you'll get them in two weeks
before Saint Patrick's Day or any size
any quantity that you want there really
so cute I mean we made them for st.
Patrick's Day but they're really just to
have year round because you should be
kissed because you're toasting yeah
tomorrow is Thursday and on Friday of
this week we're going to be joined by
toaster and fell
model Emily didn't odda which is very
exciting if you have questions for her
we'll put up a guest card on her
Instagram at the morning tell us follow
us we're almost at 200,000 followers so
the morning toast follow us maybe like
leave a comment share with your friend
power of the choice we need to get more
toasters like share with your friend
okay mm-hmm thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where you live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube Roosevelt is practice
anywhere products be found so Spotify
Achin stitcher public media radio
cashbox all the places wherever you
choose to listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast hi how are you
leave a comment subscribe five stars
maybe a comment about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are I don't know
we love you guys so much thank you so
much for listening have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow